[Music]
have you thought about scaling your app
up to meet a sudden search in demand or
scaling it down to manage costs
I'm going to show how Google kubernetes
engine also known as gke can help you
build scalable modern Cloud applications
and efficiently
let's get started gke is a fully managed
environment for deploying scaling and
managing modern Cloud applications
it is the most scalable and automated
platform
only gke can run 15 000 node clusters
outscaling other Cloud providers by up
to 10 times
letting you run applications effectively
and reliably at scale
customers like Planet Labs have already
experienced the benefits of running
their apps on gke the most scalable
platform with up to 15 000 nodes
now let
the demo from the Google Cloud console
on how gke manages to scale to 15K nodes
here we are in the Google Cloud console
under kubernetes engine tab where we
have a test cluster created with
approximately 5000 nodes
[Music]
now we have started the deployment of
additional nodes for scaling
[Music]
we will be speeding up the demo to not
make you wait
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
notes scaled up in less than 10 minutes
you should also note the stability of
the control plane during the scaling
never broke SLO the API latency was also
at 95 percentile
thank you
foreign
[Music]
I hope the demo gives you a sneak peek
of the infinite possibilities of scale
offered by gke and inspires you to take
advantage of gke like many of our
existing users
[Music]
get started today and build your app on
gke to experience its transformative
value and be prepared to scale up or
down based on your business needs
foreign
[Music]